salut il ya quelques temps il ya francs
cropper ce qui m'a contacté pour me
proposer qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble
j'ai trouvé ça plutôt cool je
connaissais sa chaîne via thibault in
shape les gens on a décidé de faire
ensemble une vidéo sur les réactions
face à l'agression en clair comment un
corps de l'âge comme celui-ci peut-il se
défendre direction le deux jours
[Musique]
et je suis donc à y est enfin maintenant
avec monsieur franck francs cropper hors
pair ce maillot parce à ça va alors je
me ferais prononcé depuis le début du
rappeur seul à survivre
ce mec là il associe la self défense
mais avec le mental et le physique alors
tu parles d un matériel quels sont les
éléments simples qui peut me permettre
de mettre en sécurité sur sur un vrai
contact physique
à un moment donné il ya ce qu'on appelle
la rupture tu vas forcément bascule en
mode physique en mode agression alors
après il faut dire les choses il y a
quatre profils d'agresser ans tu vas
devoir en fait agir en fonction des
profils toi c'est pas un problème parce
que tu vas vite détecté un peu comment
il fonctionne alors on va les faire très
rapidement pendant 4 tu as l'agresseur
isolé isolé mais programme est en fait
il a décidé et il la déceler antoine
victime comme s'il était encore de l'âge
moyen de faire parce que c'est la plage
c'est pas dans le physique à y aller
petit bonhomme fou furieux et les
coteaux qui valent rien dans des
situations réelles parce que ici c'est
faible de cheveux peut être que vous
parle cette agression programmée à
programmer son attaque soit pour te
voler soit en terme d' agression
sexuelle donc c'est quelqu'un si tu
opposes la force la détermination il
peut lâcher facilement parce que ce
qu'il veut c'est la facilité
lui c'est le professeur de l'agression
j'ai décidé que cela c'est une victime
s'y voit quelques difficultés il va
lâcher la faire parce que il est lucide
il a programmé deuxième catégorie c'est
l'agresseur qui n'ont programmé alors là
c'est souvent gars qu'est ce que
stupéfiants sous alcool est lui par
contre n'est pas quelqu'un qui va lâcher
facilement puisqu'il n'a pas la capacité
à tout comprendre
à t'écouter donc celui-là
malheureusement je vais être dur avec
toi parfois le faire du mal pour cesser
alors encore une fois je t'apprendrai ya
les techniques une technique de badges à
qu'il faut faire face ce genre
d'individus donc ça c'est le deuxième le
troisième très compliqué c'est ce qu'on
appelle la bande organisée cinq six
garçons ont décidé de faire la bonne
affaire du mas gsa le 6 janvier 2006 et
j'ai fini aux urgences
voilà alors là c'est compliqué puisqu'il
ya là il ya les supériorités numériques
ya le fait qu'ils ont bien décidé et qui
vont s'organiser avec une stratégie
pourtant trouver des fonds c'est ça va
être compliqué c'est là que tu peux pas
t'en sortir très compliqué et enfin la
quatrième catégorie c'est les agresseurs
en groupe non organisés ont cassé le
petit marin qui va chauffer les autres
dans ce prêtre sous alcool
là tu peux t'en sortir puisqu'il n'y a
pas de structure donc elle s'effectuera
jce vite et tu frappe très fort et tout
donc voilà alors maintenant on a vu
qu'il y avait des gens qui se trompent
aurait sonné les gens par exemple à
prendre la chose à faire quand tu es une
agression soit effectuée quitte à faire
c'est mettre tes mains devant le fait de
mettre les mains devant ça fait un
barrage sicot logique je veux pas
d'histoires faut pas se mettre en garde
sur tous les services et pas agressifs
et en même surtout par alors je dois
faire ça la paix universelle comme on
dit ça peut être la discussion et où
mélanie de rien tant capacité avec ses
antennes charest savait antenne 2 blocs
éventuellement une frappe alors c'est
très gênant visuellement aussi pour moi
qu'il a tout compris n'ont qu'à l'aspect
physique c'est l'aspect bouclier
barrages avec des antennes pour pouvoir
réagir au cas où on est dans un certain
seuil rythme cardiaque 158 stations
environ tu fasses reptilien donc les
blocages qu'on apprend en sable ne
fonctionneront pas c'est ceux qui sont
attirés par contre le fait d'avoir les
mains à bagdad de pouvoir bloquer à la
source la phrase est hyper important tu
sais c'est l'aspect psychologique
le barrage ça gêne et puis moi je veux
pas d'histoires je fais un paparazzi se
dit souvent j'apprends ça fait
exactement un an et ça gêne et même si
la cluse la frappe arrivent elles à
prendre en fin de course après la
deuxième chose à faire c'est un modèle
et si tu sens que ça bascule c'est de
réagir tout de suite en frappant par
contre il faut faire des phrases simples
d'accord et des frappes qui sont proches
du reptilien à savoir où on met en
fonction des mouvements moteur grossier
ça veut dire des choses qui vont pas te
demander trop de réflexion moi je dis
moi je le cerveau monsieur même un truc
sur ta chaîne qui partait comme ça grâce
à ce jeu c'est tout jamais j'aurais
pensé à ça à quoi toi en fait si tu veux
si un cahier des charges est fait en
termes de self défense et le moins de
technique possible en fait ces
techniques que tu vas toucher les points
vitaux
c'est pas forcément beau mais c'est
efficace pourquoi parce que tu vas pas
faire a trop de réflexion réelle faut
que je me positionne comme si que langue
de mon doigt ma clé
non c'est des frappes directes chemin le
plus court possible d'accord avec des
mouvements moteur grossier des grosses
larmes c'est le sabre et tient à pouvoir
suivre qui est compliqué de faire un peu
tourner ça c'est pour les arts martiaux
dans la rue ce n'est pas possible parce
que c'est pas la même niveau du cerveau
c'est plus profond s'être égarés lors
des diverses
voilà donc moi si j'avais hâte apprendre
une technique c'est de dire un habitué
des mises en situation de stress le
pouce et régulièrement pour que tu
habites tu t'habitues aux insultes tu
t'habilles sud à la pression
psychologique de l'agresseur t'habituer
chapalain connus dont on savoure le
morizet première chose c'est hyper
intéressant la répétition pour
l'appréciation vraiment ne pas avoir à
conscientiser ce que tu vas faire après
quoi voilà donc le premier un truc c'est
éviter l'inconnu donc je vais toucher
plusieurs fois je vais d'insulter une
trentaine de fois tu vas voir ton
cerveau il est habitué aux insultes
deuxièmement c'est mettre ses mains
c'est super chiant ce qu'orange tu vois
la typo avec troisième chose c'est
apprendre des techniques passe-partout
très simple que tu peux faire en simple
une fois que tu connais le type
d'agresseur une fois qu'ils habitent une
situation stressante aussi bien
physiquement que mentalement tu te
mettais vingt neuf ans et apprend
qu'après l'été la problématique chez toi
comme tu quelqu'un biais des ducs et
c'est justement switcher quand il faudra
rester ça c'est de déterminer un an le
moment voilà alors en fait c'est un
choix qui peut m'en personnel alors ça
se travaille
là on ne peut pas travailler ça travail
des mises en situation en fait je vais
t'apprendre à gérer jusqu'au seuil de
stress et abandonné tu va le sentir tu
ne pourra plus gérer physiquement et
mentalement alors physiquement si
souvent l'iata cardiovasculaires comme
tu n'es pas un physique de base tu vas
sentir que tu vas commencé à suffoquer
tu vas paniquer là je vais te dire fuck
you parce que si tu attends tu vas te
soumettre et lui va se renforcer parce
qu'il va sortir la domination par contre
aux psychologiquement ça donc c'est pas
toi seul le salaire des gens qui ne sont
pas habitués qu'on un seuil très
important d'arriver à la bascule
la bascule c'est le moment où cela étant
pas de tir et la problématique c'est que
la self défense comme ton métier ça se
travaille en amont c'est pas le jour j
que pour les élections voilà il par
exemple c'est ridicule de dire à
quelqu'un de ton poids que ton gabarits
d'aller
chercher le combat mais le royal face
aux gains qui a entraîné donc tu va
utiliser oublier utiliser la ruse la
stratégie mental pour l'affaiblir et
pouvoir soit sauvé c'est le meilleur des
cas j'aurais dit non au financement il
est triste à dire qu'elle veut dire des
choses mais si tu sais que tu vas faire
autrement tu dis l'afojel parce que si
je dure ça peut être bon pour moi parce
qu'il ya la supériorité physique c'est
ta détermination est à capacité à
connaître ce qu'on appelle le profil de
l'agresseur
les gens pensent que rolala ça va pas
bien se passer mes jambes je tremble je
sens la blancheur du visage mais non
c'est l'adrénaline mais ces excellentes
c'est pour mieux te sauver c'est pour
mieux combattre moins sentir les coups
qui fait couper comme le sang est partie
des périphéries saab sauvé la vie les
gens qui trompe c'est normal c'est tout
vient à l'énergie bien pour courir est
en fait une fois que tu sais que c'est
pour te rendre service et non pas te
mettre en difficulté mais exploite c'est
ton arme ce qui fait à des gendres petit
gabarit qui lors d'une aversion pète un
câble et démonte un costaud à c'est
hyper intéressant mais merci beaucoup
feront rien merci à toi je sais pas
exactement ce que j'avais pas vu je
pensais qu'on allait faire des démos
mais en fait je pourrais tu as l'air si
bien que ça coûtait je pars je fais ça
clame 1 c'était génial je vous conseille
vraiment sincèrement de découvrir la
chaîne de franck parce que pour tout ce
que tu dis là quand je regarde la vidéo
de franck ça me rappelle de ce qui peut
se passer que ça existe et comme ça
existe c'est à dire je peux me préparer
et c'est pas grave
et avec un truc très rations qui a dans
les vidéos 30 qui est la meilleure
solution c'est la fuite donc si tu
analyses tout si tu es capable d'avoir
une conscience à 360 extra ça va t'aider
et là je vous en dit trop la suite ça se
passe sur la chaîne de franck ropers
merci beaucoup franck me voilà de retour
au bureau je pense qu'on fera une suite
à cette vidéo avec franck sur la chaîne
d'ici peut-être 6 mois ou en fin d'année
pour aller dans les techniques
physiquement parlant vraiment sur le sur
le tapis j'ai rencontré vraiment
quelqu'un de génial je veux le remercier
encore une fois très agréable est
extrêmement intéressant dans son domaine
comme d'habitude vous pouvez cliquer
cette vidéo et vous abonner avant de
partir et rendez vous
très bientôt sûrement samedi matin ciao
[Musique]